Let's do some integer and
rational number problems.
So this first one here, the tick
marks on the number line
represent evenly spaced
integers.
And just in case you forgot
what integers mean, that
essentially is the counting
numbers, including 0 and the
negative counting numbers.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, those
are all integers.
0 is an integer.
Negative 1, negative
2, negative 3, and
so on and so forth.
Those are all integers.
You might imagine the whole
numbers, those are also
another way of saying
the integers.
So they say find the values
of a, b, c, d and e.
So these are evenly spaced, and
this is 0 right here, and
this is 21.
Let's see how many tick
marks it takes us to
go from 0 to 21.
We have one tick mark, 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7 tick marks.
So 7 tick marks take us to 21
and they're evenly spaced--
they tell us that --evenly
spaced tick marks.
So if 7 of these take us
to 21, there must be 3.
Each must be a jump of 3.
This must be 3, 6, 9, 12, 15,
18, and then bam, 21.
And the way I figured that out,
I said 7 tick marks gets
us to 21, 21 divided by
7 tick marks is 3.
So each of those increment by 3,
so this goes to 0 and then
this must be 3 to the
left of that.
So it's negative
3 right there.
So what are a, b, c and
d? a is negative 3.
a is equal to negative 3.
Right there, that's a 3.
b is equal to 3 right there.
c is equal to 9 right there.
d is equal to 12, and
e is equal to 15.
Not too bad.
All right.
Determine what fraction of the
whole each shaded region
represents.
All right.
Well let's see.
Here we have 3 sections
of this pie.
So in our denominator, which is
the bottom of our fraction
we'll write there's 3 possible
pieces, and only one of the
possible 3 sections is shaded.
So 1/3 is shaded.
So this first one is 1/3.
The second one is how many
sections do we have, and all
the sections are equal sized,
so we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 sections.
How many are shaded?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So it is 7/12.
That's what this shaded
region represents.
And then here, let's see, how
many squares do we have?
We have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7 along this side.
And then we have 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10 along that side.
So we have a total of 70
squares, 7 times 10.
And let's count how many
are shaded in.
Well this is going to
be 7 right there.
This is 7 right there, that
is 7 right there,
that is 7 right there.
So let me add this up.
So so far I have 28,
that's 7 times 4.
28 plus, let's see, I have
2-- this is 2, 2, 2,
2, 2, 2, 2 and 2.
So how many 2's are there.
That's 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8 2's.
So that 8 times 2, that's 16.
So 28 plus 16.
28 plus 10 is 38 plus
another 6 is 44.
So we have 44 of the 70
squares filled in.
And we can write this rational
number in simpler form.
We can simplify it.
Let's see, the numerator and
the denominator both are
divisible by 2.
So this is equal
to 22 over 35.
And that's about as simple
as we can get.
This is divisible by 2 and 11.
This is not divisible
by either 2 or 11.
So there you go.
That's the fraction
in simplest form.
Problem 3.
Place the following sets of
rational numbers in order from
least to greatest.
So let's do part a.
I might not do all of these
for the sake of time.
1/2, 1/3 and 1/4.
So if you think about a pie,
going on, if you take a pie
and you divide it into just
2 pieces, 1/2 is half
of that whole pie.
That right there is 1/2.
This right here, 1/4, 1/4 is--
you just take the same pie
--1/4 is just that.
So clearly 1/2 is greater than
1/4 or 1/4 is less than 1/2.
I'll write it like that.
And 1/3 is right in between.
If you did 1/3-- it's maybe
harder to visualize here --but
if this is 1/2, if we divided
this into thirds, 1/3
is less than this.
So if we divided this into
thirds, 3 equals sections, 1/3
would be just like
that right here.
1/3 is more than that.
There's multiple ways we
could visualize this.
So 1/4 is less than 1/3,
which is less than 1/2.
In general, the larger
your denominator
the smaller the fraction.
I have only one 1 of 4, that's
less than 1 out of 3, and
that's even less than 1 out of
2, which would be even less
than 1 out of 1.
So that's our first one.
We put that in order:
1/4, 1/3, 1/2.
Let me just do part to c, just
for the sake of time.
So we have 39 over 60, we
have 49 over 80, and we
have a 59 over 100.
So the easiest way to do this,
if you had a calculator you
would actually just divide each
of these numbers out and
you would get a decimal, and
it's very easy to compare
decimal numbers.
But let's if we can do this a
little bit more artfully.
So we can approximate it.
We could say that this
is a little bit less.
So 39 over 60, it's almost--
I'll make those squiggly equal
signs for almost --it's
approximately 40 over 60,
which is equal to 2/3.
So this is almost 2/3.
A little bit less than 2/3.
This right here, 49 over 80,
it's almost 50 over 80, so
it's almost 5/8.
And then this right here, 59
over 80-- 59 over 100, sorry.
It's almost equal to 60 over
100, which is equal to 3/5.
And just to get a sense of, at
least now we might be able to
do it in our head, 2/3,
that's approximately
equal to 0.66 repeating.
You could say 0.667, roughly
equal to that.
That's the 2/3 right there.
Let me do it in that
color so you know
what I'm talking about.
So this is approximately 0.667,
not exactly, we're
estimating.
This right here, 5/8-- So the
way I always think of eighths
is 1/8 is .125.
So 5/8-- Let me just divide
it right here, let
me just do the work.
So if we take 8 goes into 5, put
some decimals right here,
8 goes into 5 zero times,
0 times 8 is 0.
5 minus 0 is 5.
Bring down this 0.
8 goes into 50 six times.
6 times 8 is 48.
50 minus 48 is 2,
bring down a 0.
8 goes into 20 two times.
2 times 8 is 16.
Subtract, you get a 4.
Bring down this 0.
40.
8 goes into 40 five times.
So this right here is 0.625.
Not exactly, it's a little
bit less than this.
This is a little bit
less than that.
And 3/5 is pretty
straightforward.
3/5 is the same thing
as 6/10, which is
approximately equal to 0.6.
So this is a little bit less
than 0.6, this is a little bit
less than .625, this is a little
bit less than .667.
So if you put them in order,
this is the smallest, then
this one, then that one.
So let me write it down.
So the smallest is 59 over 100,
followed by 49 over 80,
followed by the largest,
which is 39 over 60.
Which might be a little
unintuitive because this
actually has the smallest number
in the numerator, but
it also has the smallest number
in the denominator.
So you actually had
to work it out.
They're actually reasonably
close to each other.
Let's do problem number 5.
Find the opposite of each
of the following.
And when they say opposite,
I think they mean find the
negative, or find the reflection
on the number line.
So we essentially just have to
multiply all of these numbers
by negative 1.
So for part a, the opposite of
1.001 would be negative 1.001.
For part b, the negative of 5
minus 11-- well we could write
it --it's going to be negative
1 times-- Well,
what's 5 minus 11?
5 minus 11 is negative 6.
This number right here
is negative 6.
So the opposite of negative 6--
negative 1 times negative
6 --is going to be equal to 6.
Part c.
x plus y.
The opposite's going to be
negative 1 times x plus y, or
we could have just written
negative times x plus y.
You distribute the negative 1.
This is equal to negative x,
and then negative 1 times
plus y minus y.
Finally, part d.
Negative 1 times x minus y.
I'm just taking the negative
of everything.
So I'm taking the negative of
this, and so this is going to
equal to negative 1 times
x, negative x.
Then negative 1 times minus y or
negative y, that's plus y.
Or we could write this
as y minus x.
And that's actually a neat thing
to remember later on
when you're manipulating
things algebraically.
The negative of x minus
y is y minus x.
We just did that right there.
The negative of a minus
b is b minus a.
You just swap the two when you
take the negative, and we just
proved it for you right there.
All right.
Let's do a couple of these.
Simplify the following absolute
value expression.
Absolute value is essentially
telling you the
distance from 0.
So for example, if that's 0,
if I have the number 4.
How far is 4 from 0?
The absolute value of 4?
Well it's 4 from 0.
So you just say it's 4.
So the absolute value
of positive
numbers is just the number.
Let's say I had negative 3.
How far is negative 3 from 0?
Well, I don't care whether it's
to the left of the right
of 0, it's just 3
away from the 0.
It's 3 to the left.
So this is going to be 3.
So one way to think about
absolute value is, whether
it's positive or negative,
it becomes positive.
It's that far from 0.
So let's do these.
So 11 minus the absolute
value of negative 4.
This is equal to 11 minus-- the
absolute of negative 4 is
just 4, which is equal to 7.
I'll do every other one of these
problems. The absolute
value of negative 5 minus 11.
So that'll be equal to the
absolute value of negative 5
minus 11 is negative 16.
The absolute value
of negative 16.
the absolute value of negative
16 is just 16.
It's 16 to the left of 0.
You could view it that
way, you could just
get rid of its sign.
And then finally here,
let's do part e.
The negative of the absolute
value of negative 7 is equal
to the negative of--
What's the absolute
value of negative 7?
It's just 7.
So it's equal to negative 7.
This right here is 7.
Anyway, hopefully you
found that useful.